foreign
to be in an unfamiliar space after dark
by myself this is your body telling you
you're not safe where does that where's
that come from several years ago like 15
16 years ago I had a break-in in my
house and was attacked by a convicted
rapist Elizabeth lead with that
[Music]
what up what up this is John the Dr John
baloney show I'm so glad that you joined
us
man it's good to see you good to hear
from you
pull up a seat at the bar and we're
gonna hang out we're gonna figure out
what's going on with your mental health
with your relationships with your
marriage with your kids this is the
greatest mental health marriage and
pairing podcast that's ever existed
we've talked about everything from
education to policies to what's going on
in your world man and so however I can
help give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask ask and you can fill out the little
internet form and hit
sin and it goes to Jenna and she will
give you a buzz and get you on the show
today is a special Thanksgiving
gratitude episode so hang in for the
entire show we got something really cool
for you at the back end but until we get
there let's go straight to the phones
let's go to Mankato Minnesota and talk
to Edward what's up Edward
just rocking on to the break of dawn
John how are you that's me too me too
except it's like the middle of the
morning but the party never stops Snoop
Dogg what's up man I'm actually kidding
I've got two kids so when they're
sleeping I'm sleeping right and even
when they're awake I'm sleeping uh good
for you man um
so the question comes up from uh some
lightning round questions you did about
marriage and
the question was how do you maintain
intimacy with small kids at home and you
know you said we don't and if you've got
two kids five and under it's a sex free
zone for a long time and I've got two
kids under five so one's five and the
other one's two yes
um
and then you went on to explain you know
how you plan it and schedule it okay
cool and so
um you know my wife and I we have
certain forms of intimacy that we you
know holding hands and hugging and
kissing and we do that all in front of
the kids
um to show what a husband and a wife
looks like you know a healthy
relationship so the question becomes you
know how do we help our kids understand
that
those boundaries are for for married
couples and adult
um you know hugging your mom and your
dad and your grandparents is okay but
say like your friends and your teacher
you don't just go up and give them a hug
and a kiss it's not
it's that type of affection is for
um certain people
is
is that happening or are y'all worried
about that happening
um so at daycare one time our oldest had
hugged and gave a kiss to another kid so
that happened once okay
um and I I it hasn't happened
otherwise but it's a concern okay I I
would not lose a single ounce of sleep
over that not for one second
there tends to be a
um socialization that limits that
um occasionally there are kids that are
over affectionate and
um it's as simple as hugs and kisses or
for family members
hugs and kisses are for very very close
friends and we ask permission so
something s like low level
is not always but occasionally my wife
will say can I have a morning hug
I always ask my daughter for permission
to give her a hug
um and I'm trying to teach her that
she's in control of her body
um if my wife and I do hug in the
morning in front of the kid it's like a
big demonstrative thing but I also want
to caution you against this
don't use each other
as a chalkboard
meaning hug your wife because you love
love your wife
ask your wife
um
like
can I have a hug
um can I give you a big kiss like do
that because you want to kiss your wife
not because you want to demonstrate what
a healthy marriage is if you truly and
deeply engage in Acts of intimacy both
behind closed doors and in front of
closed doors with your spouse
that comes the lesson comes through but
when you make each other an object
lesson
it really can get wonky quick because
you start wondering why someone's doing
something or are they doing it on
purpose you see what I'm saying it
starts getting messy and so I would lean
directly into that I I wouldn't worry
about that one second I I I'm making the
data up here but I would say 95 percent
of kids
um
are gonna hug each other they're gonna
hold hands they're going to
um be close with one another they're
gonna bang and bonk into each other
because they're trying to establish
space in relational space and that's
that is why I like school that's there's
some socialization there this is
appropriate here not appropriate here
um but on the whole most kids understand
they have a innate sense of safety with
their home crew that makes hugs and
other things more okay than in other
places and then occasionally I've had to
have conversations with my kids I worked
with one family
um
and their son was big for his age and he
was
um
like always ending up playing with
younger kids and then they had built a
huge like Fort like a fort on one of the
kids beds at a neighbor's house and the
neighbor had like three young girls
and so they didn't know how to have the
conversation with this younger boy I
think he was nine or ten hey it's
inappropriate for you to be under the
covers with three little girls and he he
simply couldn't understand it he and it
wasn't even in his head and so we had to
talk about appropriate right it's not
appropriate with other people's so that
was just a simple we we they called me
and I walked him through how to have
that conversation ended up being hard
harder than they thought but but overall
simple just address the behavior as it
happens
okay
sure um are you you're you're not this
is all you're just worried about this
happening down the road
kind of yeah and I guess one was we were
out front in our yard you know watering
collars or something in the
nice little old lady walked by and and
as she was passing the boys are just
like I want to go give her a hug so they
ran up to her and gave her a hug and
stuff and I was like okay that was it
was really sweet but also it's like okay
well who who are they always going to
want to give hugs to in certain
um things like that so that is that's a
if you find your kids like at a Walmart
giving hugs to tons of strangers
that's when you have a quiet
conversation this isn't an appropriate
place and you can point back to you
um Mommy and Daddy give each other hugs
Daddy hugs his friends at at work or
Daddy hugs his friends when they come
over my son sees me hug other men
regularly
my son sees me hug my friend's wives and
um women that I'm close to that I'm
friends with they don't see me kiss them
right and so I can point back to me as a
model for I hug Mr Todd and I hug Mr
John and I hug Mr Nathan I don't hug
strange men at Walmart
because I don't know them and I don't
have that sort of it's all right so
these are these are gentle teaching
moments also if they say I want to go
give that old woman a hug
all you have to say is make sure you ask
her for her permission that's it and let
him go run and they can run on the
street and she can say no thank you or
she she can have her entire world made
because two little boys came and gave
her a hug right
um right and so that's what my wife had
said is you don't know what kind of day
she was having that could have just made
her whole day I I would be willing to
bet it did but I do like the practice of
um whenever I'm at book signings or I
was just in Dallas for a huge event
thousands of people people came up and
they really quickly like I'm signing
their book and they really quickly will
say something heavy like I was thinking
about suicide and I got your book and it
helped or I was in a really abusive
relationship and you're you gave me the
courage to step out I'll often look at
them and I'll say can I give you a hug I
never hug somebody without especially a
stranger without asking you permission
can I give you a hug male female I don't
care who
um police officer to an elderly Grandma
right I asked the permission and I think
that's a great thing to model for your
sons what we don't want to do is I don't
want to take away that inclination for
hugging for human connection human touch
I don't want that to be registered in
their little Minds as bad or as of
something to avoid I think that that's
one of the things in our culture that's
killing us
I I may have talked about this on the
show one of the places I worked years
ago during the HR onboarding process
they recommended the air high five
and I was like what
and there was like 50 of us in this in
this onboarding meeting and they said
yeah if if one of your colleagues does
something great gets a huge Grant or
gets a publication we recommend the air
high five to avoid confusion
and I was like what kind of confusion
and they said just we want to avoid
unwanted touch
and I was like man there are some
creepers who have just blown it for
everybody and what we've created is a
completely Touch free society and I
don't think that's ever existed before
and there are people who abuse touch
right that's look go back and read the
me too transcripts man of bosses who
slap people on the butt or who hug too
much or grope a little like so it's
disgusting so we gotta strike a balance
we gotta teach our kids a modeling is
the best but B
um I don't want them to learn that touch
is bad I want them to to learn there's
an appropriate touch and there's a
welcome touch and there's an unwelcome
touch right I don't think you're
anywhere near that right now I think
with just one or two sentences uh one or
two go make sure you ask is it okay for
to give you a hug
man what a great gift you're teaching
your sons which is they know that their
touch to that old woman is therapeutic
and healing and life-giving and they
asked for consent which I think is
important
sure has everyone's been doing I guess
the yeah and we haven't been doing the
ask for consent but usually like when we
say goodbye to let's say a grandparent
or something we say do you want to go
give so-and-so a hug and then they yes
and go run up and give a hug so yeah hey
I will make sure let me tell you this
let me tell you this that's huge
um I really am grossed out when a
Grandpa's like come give me a kiss and
the the granddaughter says no thank you
you're not gonna kiss your granddad nope
like and I a good for you do you asking
your children do you want to go give
Granddad a hug you wanna give grandma a
hug before she goes
um I'm going to give grandma a hug do
you want to come with me I think that's
phenomenal because you're letting the
kid have body autonomy and you're
letting them have it and
um letting them take ownership of their
body and they're watching you do it good
for you man you're right on track
brother
all right yeah way to go man um parents
hug your sons hug your daughters and
invite them into that and a little
vocalization doesn't hurt
um it's welcoming hey hun can I give you
a big hug this morning
um
I think that's a gift here
and teaching them about consent is
awesome good for you good for you hey
we'll be right back
[Music]
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor better help let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back let's go to
Elizabeth in Dallas Texas what's up
Elizabeth
hey Dr deloney thanks for taking my call
you got it you doing well
I'm well how about you very very good
very very good what's up so I have sort
of an embarrassing silly problem but hey
hold on hold on hold on hold on have you
met me
that's true whatever you're about to say
you're good you're good
there's just a few million people
listening you are you are just between
us don't worry about it there you go all
right so what's up
um basically like I'm afraid to be in an
unfamiliar space
um after dark by myself essentially like
so hotels Airbnb like it can even be a
friend's house like
um so like spending the night somewhere
like I can do it like in a hotel I don't
love it but I can like force myself
um but like an actual house or something
with more entry points no forget it okay
so number one this isn't silly or weird
it's not common but it's not weird Okay
um if you've if you've listened to the
show for any length of time you'll know
I'll ask like
pulling the thread on this this is your
body telling you you're not safe where
does that where's that come from
well
we've had it like you do when you're a
kid you're afraid of the dark you're
afraid to be alone and I never outgrew
it but then
um I'm sure obviously you saw the notes
but several years ago like 15 16 years
ago
um I had a break-in in my house and was
attacked by a convicted rapist
essentially which Elizabeth lead with
that
I feel like I've worked through that
like I feel like I went to counseling
like like the issue was already there
and I guess that just compounded it but
I feel like it doesn't bother me like I
don't think about it like I could go
take a jog outside at night but if you
put me inside of a house that's when the
fears come and that's where like the
irrational like you know that I check
all the doors or you know can you get in
that window you know whatever sure
um did your folks do that
no not at all okay like we grew up in
the country I doubt the door was even
locked half the time and that's
also the ironic thing like I could
forget to lock my own door and in a way
that kind of makes me feel better
because I know like
um it's not so
ingrained I guess you know like my own
door would be I mean I might in the
morning be like whoops forgot that you
know and I shouldn't have done that but
it's not so much like in my own space
but if you were to like go out of town
and you would say hey can you watch my
dogs or whatever I would gladly do so
but then like if it involves going to
your house at night forget it like even
if it's just go in your house for 10
minutes like I would have a panic attack
and forget it no I'd be out like so is
this something that you want to be
different or is this something that
you're willing to just make peace with
and there's not a right or wrong answer
to this
great to be different because I would
like to be able to
um I won't say I don't dread trips or
things like that but
like I'm potentially taking a job that's
going to require travel which is fine
that's great okay but I would like to
not feel like I'm sleeping with one eye
open or you got it you got it
so I um
I'm writing a note here
so
for some reason and I don't even think
it matters why this is just I don't I
don't I don't think it matters your body
has identified
unfamiliar places at night as a no-go
not safe okay it's put a GPS pin in that
and every time you find yourself in that
situation or leaning towards that
situation it sounds your alarms right
and
because we're people and we have giant
frontal lobes
we can spin our bodies up even thinking
about going to a house at night right
and I bet you could tell me a story in
about three minutes and your heart would
start racing really fast just thinking
about it oh yeah that's that's what a
great gift we have right we don't even
have to have to do the scary thing we
can just think about it and make
ourselves nuts
so here's the the good news is you can
go through your life and just kind of
make your way around it and that's fine
right and that's that's essentially what
I've done like I just avoid those
situations or you can heal from this and
I've got good news and bad news good
news is you can totally heal from this
bad news is there's one way to heal and
it is directly through the middle of
this I knew you were gonna say that
that's the only way and so
your brain your your thinking brain has
made peace this happened I went to
counseling from the break-in from the um
the the near traumatic rape like I made
peace of that I'm not even I don't even
when I think about it my heart rate
doesn't even get up yeah but as as
Bessel vanderkolk says your body's
keeping the score it does okay so
um
making peace with your past healing from
your past is a has a thought component
to it I can think about this I can think
about the loss I can think about the
near break-in and I'm fine and then
there's another healing part that is
much much much deeper which is my body
doesn't take off on me
my body's at peace too and that's the
level of healing we're looking for here
so there's one way through it and that's
to practice
and what that might look like is getting
a couple of friends that you trust
and saying
I need to go into your house and walk
around for 15 minutes after dark with
you not there
and I know that sounds crazy and what
you're going to do is you're going to
walk in the front door
and you are going to begin to feel your
body and here's what we're looking to do
create a space a gap they call it you're
going to create a gap between I think
I'm going to die like my body is
starting to react like there's somebody
upstairs and this is all coming down on
me yeah and your Consciousness like no
I'm not I'm okay this is Dan's house
this is Tim's house this is Sue's house
this is you know Laura's apartment
and we're going to practice it and you
are literally going to walk in there and
begin to feel it and it may be that
you're planning on doing this for 15
minutes and you can last three minutes
the first time cool
keep a little log and write it down
and then you're gonna go to a hotel and
you are gonna walk into the hotel and
you're just gonna stop for a second and
feel what your body's doing
and all we're doing is connecting our
thinking and our responding brains we
want our responding brain to know
there's danger oh she's still driving
cool we can turn the alarms off guys she
knows what's up
that's it
okay and it's just gonna take some time
and by the way I travel for a living I
still don't sleep super great in hotels
I track my sleep with this whoop strap
it lets me know you didn't get a good
night's sleep I just don't sleep well
when I'm not at home and I've made peace
with that that means if I'm gonna
function if I'm gonna get on stage in
front of 5 000 people the next day I
have to have overly ate eaten right
every time I go to a hotel the first
thing I do I don't even unpack no I
unpack I go straight to the gym and I
get my head screwed on straight I get my
body screwed on straight before I do
anything else before I go to soundcheck
before I go to I even fly into towns
early for that reason
because I know the third
um the third component of my Wellness
one is nutrition one is movement and the
other sleep I know I'm not going to get
the Sleep part I just know it and I've
made peace with it I don't fight it I
don't get frustrated anymore I don't go
to war with it
um but that's just the way that's going
to be so you may never totally pass out
in a hotel
but you can you can prop your feet up
and watch TV watch the office and enjoy
life without yeah your body rattling on
does that make sense
no it does but
like the thought of that I know
it gives me anxiety just thinking about
it it absolutely does absolutely and
again that's your body just trying to
take care of you
because while you've gone off and done
your cute little counseling Elizabeth to
forget all this stuff the body knows we
could get murdered at any second right
and here's this the sucky part you might
you might but probably not
right and maybe but probably not is the
sentence that gets me through everything
it could but probably not maybe right
but probably not there could be any but
I I
all right I'll just be honest with you
when I walk into my friend's house to
feed their dogs at night
my heart starts racing about 200 beats a
minute like I literally think I'm gonna
die
and I have to say no I'm not like I'm
smiling because you and I have a very
similar phobia congratulations we win
um and it just is it just is and I've
made peace with it and now I can go get
my job done I'm never gonna enjoy it I'm
ever gonna love it but I can go get it
get done what I need to get done
okay
okay so what are you going to do next
what's your first first thing you're
gonna do
I guess I'll probably call a friend and
they spend some time in our house I want
you to call three friends
and here's I want you to get weird about
this
okay call three friends and I want you
to see if you can rotate for
um every night for 30 days
just for a few minutes at a time right
just start with start with five minutes
start with three minutes
hey Laura this is gonna I'm gonna have
the weirdest thing I have a super phobia
I've never told you about it freaks me
out I'm about to take this new job I
talked to this knucklehead on a podcast
and
um this guy that used to have a real job
and now he's a YouTuber and He suggests
I do this can I borrow your house for
five minutes I just need you to walk
around the yard while I stand in your
house I saw him on Tick Tock it's fine
there you go
um I talked to this Tick Tock sensation
and uh I I need to
make a lap upstairs and downstairs in
your home with the lights off for five
minutes
and I do want you to do that whether I
want you to get a flashlight and I want
you to walk into somebody's house and go
up their stairs and go to the end of the
hallway and then come down the stairs
and then walk out and by the way if my
friend did that I would scare the
bejesus out of them I would hide and you
know expect your friends if they're any
friend caliber at all they'll do this
um but we're just gonna teach our bodies
we're all right we can do hard stuff
I'm glad we're not friends John
you know how often I hear that
um but hey uh it's practice practice
practice practice the only true healing
from anxiety is directly through the
middle of it
gotta get connected you gotta show your
body you're not I mean that you're not
in danger that you're safe
you have to show your body that hey I'm
driving and you gotta have other people
you can talk to about this take the
stigma away from it take the shame away
from it take the secrecy away from it
hey I've got this crazy phobia this
wackadophobia I don't like spiders I
have a phobia that every time I see a
snake my body literally wants to vomit
in Diary at the same time it's like
everybody out like everything wants to
leave my body at once and I gotta heal
from that so for 15 minutes can I come
over and you know if you've got a boa
constrictor can I just look at it
through a glass and then I'm gonna get
closer and make it closer it's just cold
exposure therapy is what it is and if
you can do it safely go for it but I
think you go spend five minutes in your
friend's house then we Turn All the
Lights On you breathe and you go I made
it I made it
and then when you go out to the car sit
in your car for a second and just feel
it I made it
I did it I can do hard stuff and then
tomorrow we're gonna do this again and
then hopefully after 30 days there is a
significant reduction
and act you know
I won't go down to parasympathetic and
sympathetic but your body will stop
taking off on you and you can take this
new job and go make some money and enjoy
your life we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 in MLS
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
alright we are back and it's the
Thanksgiving episode the Gratitude where
we stop for a second and just say
I'm so grateful even if I'm grateful for
just little bitty things because
everything has been a dumpster fire this
past year or I'm really struggling
because I had a picture of what
Thanksgiving was going to look like
um thanksgiving's in a day right Kelly
thanksgiving's tomorrow I sure thought I
wasn't going to be at my in-laws yet
again or I sure thought that my whole
family is going to be here or I sure
thought that my son was coming home from
college or that my daughter was going to
be out from deployment whatever it is
it's a season when we stop and we just
say despite what's happening or
um in addition to what's happening I'm
grateful I'm gonna own it for a second
you've heard me talk about this
especially in the past I haven't talked
about as much recently and I need to I
need to be more vocal about it gratitude
a practice of gratitude
minute by minute hour by hour a daily
gratitude practice an orientation
towards a life
towards saying okay I didn't want this
to happen I didn't expect this to happen
I'm going to whether right now or in two
years I'm gonna find
gratitude I'm gonna say thank you
um whether it's to the firefighters who
showed up with my house burned to the
ground whether it was the people who
stood by me when my loved one passed
away whether it was
um
my wife isn't doing so well but I'm so
grateful that your wife's cancer is
healed right what I'm gonna have an
orientation towards finding Beauty
finding gratitude gratitude is one of
the most important psychological tenets
for a well life
what does that mean this gobbledygook
for
if you are not grateful if you don't
have a regular gratitude practice where
you stop and feel grateful you are
choosing to die early
you're choosing a miserable existence
and I would suggest why
why waste your life why
so there's I I wrote down four ways I've
heard it in the scientific literature
and uh in kind of the popular instagramy
literature which is not really
literature I take that back in the
popular instagrammy influencery nonsense
um here's four ways you can
um Express gratitude have a gratitude
practice one is just you hear this all
the time write three to five things
every day that you're grateful for keep
a journal right just have a journal that
you write them in things that you're
grateful for I am grateful for I'm
grateful for I am grateful for just do
that every day you can do it in the
morning you can do it before you go to
bed
um you can also watch somebody do great
things for somebody else
so you can
um watch a video of somebody doing
something kind for somebody else you can
listen to a story where somebody
explains and then this guy came and
helped me out she showed up this person
pulled over on the side of the road and
helped me out when I had a flat tire you
can be in that story
a third way is you can write a letter to
somebody
um I think this is
Africa I forgot the uh I need to find it
I'll put it in the show notes um he's a
psychologist at Harvard a psychology
Professor who recommends to a student's
um one of the only ways you can achieve
happiness instantaneously you can turn
the dial is to write a letter of
gratitude to somebody and then visit
with them either by phone or in person
and
um right and read it to them let them
know hey I wrote you this letter
um in all honesty I've only been able to
do that once and that was to my son
um it's very hard to do to write a
letter of gratitude to your mom or to
your dad I was with some guys this
weekend on a hunting trip and one of the
guys is going to do this for his father
um all the his father's got is is
working through some significant medical
issues and so they all wrote letters
that they're going to read
and
he had to stop the conversation because
it was it got choked up just thinking
about what he's gonna do right so it's
very hard to do that
but there's some significant
psychological healing that happens with
that and then there's another one that
that's
um that I got from Andrew huberman which
I think is phenomenal and I've had some
great success with it and it's it's
almost a meditative gratitude where I'll
turn the lights off in my basement and
I'll sit down in my normal gratitude
position if you will sitting down with
my legs out or legs folded and my back
up and I close my eyes
and I remember a moment that I'm truly
grateful for
when my dad hugged me after a thing when
my mom put her hands on my face and said
she was proud of me when my wife fill in
the blank with my son daughter filled in
the blank when I got a job and I didn't
think I was going to get it I put myself
back in that moment and it takes it can
take 60 seconds it can take three or
four minutes but I'm going to the best I
can re-experience that moment of
gratitude
that moment when I'm so grateful thank
you for showing up in my life thank you
for being there when I needed you thank
you for sitting with me when I was
grieving thank you for holding my hand
through this ugly mess thank you for
saying yes when I asked you to marry me
all these right these moments of
gratitude
um whatever it looks like for you
I challenge you from this day forward
let's do this from this day until the
new year
every day have a gratitude practice
whatever it looks like put a um put
something on your phone set an alarm and
just say gratitude practice and remind
yourself I gotta take three minutes and
write this thing down because Delaney
said to her to remember to be grateful
just do it and my promise is you will
begin to shift how you see the world it
changes the glasses by which you filter
and see the world then it's
extraordinary so very cool thing
um we reached out on social media on the
internet and I asked the people who
follow my Instagram account
um what are some things you're grateful
for would you be willing to share and we
got a bajillion responses I was hoping
for seven we got a million we got a
bunch of people saying I'm grateful for
this my dad showed up my husband's
awesome my wife is amazing my kids or
whatever okay so Kelly how many people
wrote in and told us who or what they're
grateful for we had 100 million trillion
responses yes I love John numbers
actually we had six we had six
responders
um and four of them were pets they were
the children of you dog parents out
there
it's not a thing but hey so
um we split these up so y'all pick some
of your favorite ones and so let's go
through the b double O T H and start
over there with you Jenna yes yes so um
I've got three I'm gonna read here okay
um so first one comes from traveling
cows with a k
um and they said our IVF Clinic they
helped us make our beautiful twin girls
so that's the first one um the second
one is the Adam toy said my wife for
dealing with all my anxiety and health
issues recently
and then the third one is from ape
Baldwin I am thankful for my two
brothers who have walked through the
darkest nights with me oh hey how cool
is that that who is in the middle
the Adam toy the Adam toy my wife
exacerbates my anxiety and pours
gasoline on it and his helps that's so
nice it's so great
okay who's next
Ben
uh yeah so I've got one here from I got
a few here uh first one from Red Sea
Arnold's not Cardinals C Arnold's uh
says my friend Jason he helps me combat
Suicidal Thoughts just by talking to me
dang way to go Jason Jenny Jenn 03 says
my fifth grade students this year
they're pushing me to apply so many
different approaches to my teaching is
is that because they're so ridiculous
and out of control that she's having to
come up with new things I love it good
job great students way to go and then uh
last one I've got is uh really really
Riley says a couple that set aside
Comfort uh Slash privacy and let me stay
with them for six months in college for
free wow so that's pretty baller that's
huge yes Kelly all right so miss
cerebell 20 times I didn't know you
could feel thankful oh this isn't yours
this is somebody else okay read theirs
read theirs go ahead I just hope the
people know what I what I deal with this
is It's my job well they know what I
deal with so go ahead
Miss Sarah Bell 2020 said my
mother-in-law she's a prayer Warrior and
I can talk to her about things I'm not
comfortable talking to my mom about she
has always treated me like her own
daughter how many did we get people who
are grateful for their in-laws is that
the one the one the one the white one
way to go America yeah
um at Anton dot fam said my father and
husband who have not had to do with
social media are both incredibly
supportive loving men
and then at classical voice coaching
said my high school choir director his
belief in me taught me how to believe in
myself through my Opera career
you don't hear the words Opera and
career together very often that's
fantastic man Nate Dogg what do you
think Stussy reezy says I'm thankful for
my sister she just got sober and we are
spending more time together very cool uh
of a working mom says my mom takes the
kids overnight every Friday night so my
husband and I can have a date night whoa
that sounds incredible actually yeah
yeah
uh Laura Beth says my neurologist he
saved my life and gave me an internship
as a jump start into my career wow
that's awesome uh the ones I've got are
from Corey coaster music
said my college junior varsity soccer
coach sent me on the right path and has
checked in with me for the last 10 years
you know what I love that when a teacher
or coach just reaches out I've got
students that I used to coach and teach
and I try to reach out every once in a
while
I just love it man I love seeing how
people are successful they've got
families and they've got careers and
jobs just like my it's my favorite thing
in the world I love it uh Skelly 9181
writes my childhood best friend no
matter how far apart we've lived she's
always been a huge support system
and Mason Dot algiere says my dad he's
always lends an ear to hear wise counsel
and is a rock to help keep me grounded
so red hey thanks to everybody for
writing in um we did we have we had an
overwhelming response it was awesome
this is important just take a minute uh
Jenna let's go through the booth real
fast
um curveball what somebody somebody or
something you're grateful for and
besides me we all know that that's going
to be everybody's number so besides the
opportunity to work with this stable
stable guy keep going yep
um so I would say I'm very thankful for
my mom
um for and I know she's listening
because she listens to show now
um for never giving up on me through the
hardest seasons of my life and seeing
the potential in myself that I could
never see for myself at that time
that's awesome
Benjamin
I'm going to say as cliche as it is I'm
very thankful for my wife I just had a
lot of ups and downs this year we bought
a house then we had an injury and a
layoff and I just got hit by a car you
know I didn't even get by a car you get
hit by a semi truck but true cool I was
trying to downplay it but uh but she's
always been there for me and super
supportive and couldn't have gotten
through everything without her that's
awesome
um mine would be my sister my mom is in
the last days of her life due to
Alzheimer's and it's in Texas so I'm not
there and my sister's having to deal
with all that and she's been going to
the nursing home daily making sure
hospice is doing what they need to do
and just really caring for her and
taking the brunt of that and I know how
hard that is and I very much appreciate
that she's able to do that and that she
does it with love
uh and then for me I would say uh I'm
thankful for my daughter uh two years
ago she was diagnosed with a rare form
of cancer and was told that uh she would
have a 75 chance of it coming back and
so far she has beaten the odds that's
amazing good deal man
um and I would say
hmm
I just get kind of overwhelmed with
gratitude because my life is
um just sitting on
the gifts and talents and love and care
and forgiveness of so many people
um I would probably say I'm deeply
grateful
for Todd Vachon
for Michael
you know
Kevin for Trevor and Craig for
um
JP Nate Justin these men in my life who
aren't afraid they're some of the few
who aren't afraid to say hey that's
that's not cool that's not who you are
they're not afraid to say hey
um that joke's not funny they're not
afraid to say I know you love your wife
but you didn't treat her better
um they're men that hold me accountable
they also remind me to laugh deeply they
think I vote terribly they think that
some of my politics are stupid and my
mental health advice is dumb and they
don't hesitate to let me know they also
will call and say hey
um
I don't listen to your show but I heard
one call that's what they always say
they don't listen but then they do and
that call was you did a good job you
really helped that person and so they're
not afraid to say great job too
and so
um I'm not who I am without my friends
Potts and Caleb and Ryan and Buddy and
Tucker the whole gang man I'm just so
grateful for my friends
um and then I guess at the end of the
day my best friend on planet my wife
Sheila just just people I can laugh with
and be with and hang out with and I can
only kiss one of those that's not true I
guess all my friends is cool all right
um so don't forget don't forget
be grateful make it a part of your life
make it a practice make it a regular
thing you do think for things think of
moments experience friendships remember
back to those times if we all turn the
dial to being more grateful the whole
world changes and it starts with each
one of us we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
that's what gratitude sounds like that's
what gratitude looks like
choose gratitude
choose to be grateful choose to find the
moments amidst amidst the fire and the
smoke and the ugliness
and the grittiness and the scraping and
the raw the hard parts of life
choose to look for things you're
grateful for choose to be grateful
and if you're really a gangster choose
to let people know you're grateful for
them
um as we wrap up today's show it's
Thanksgiving episode be kind to each
other tomorrow at Thanksgiving be kind
don't talk about politics don't talk
about covid
don't Don't lecture your kids on how
they can be raising your grandkids
better
just be cool just be kind enjoy each
other's Fellowship smiled the most as
most as much as you can turn the screens
off as much as you can just go play
catch of the tennis ball do whatever you
got to do be kind be connected to one
another choose Joy choose gratitude uh
the song of the day it's I think it's
the single most romantic song ever
written like and this is me being honest
100
um
it's just such a beautiful song and it's
the song the songwriter is talking about
how grateful he is for his wife songs by
Billy Joel and it's called
she's got a way and it goes like this
she's got a way about her and I don't
know what it is but I know that I can't
live without her and she's got a way of
pleasing and I don't know what it is but
there doesn't have to be a reason anyway
she's got a smile that heals me and I
don't know why it is but I have to laugh
when she reveals me and she's got a way
of talking and I don't know why it is
but it lifts me up when we're walking
anywhere
and she comes to me when I'm feeling
down inspires me without a sound she
touches me and I get turned around
she's got a smile that heals me and I
don't know why it is but I have to laugh
when she reveals me
thank y'all for being with us Happy
Thanksgiving stay in school don't do
drugs we'll see you soon
[Music]